(rocket booming)
- [Narrator] North Korea
has unveiled a host
of new weapons in recent weeks.
They include a tactical nuclear warhead,
an underwater drone
(camera clicking)
and a solid fueled
intercontinental ballistic missile.
(cameras clicking)
The significant advances
in Pyongyang's arsenal were a major focus
of President Biden's latest talks
with his South Korean counterpart.
- Our mutual defense treaty is ironclad
and that includes our commitment
to extended deterrents
and that includes the nuclear threat
and the nuclear deterrent.
- [Narrator] We look at what Pyongyang
said their newest weapons are capable of,
and how they add to the growing
threat from North Korea.
(rocket whooshing)
(pensive music)
In late March, North Korea leader
Kim Jong Un ordered the expansion
of weapons grade nuclear material
to boost the country's arsenal.
That same week,
state media released photos
showing Kim inspecting weapons
including what North
Korea calls the Hwasan-31.
It was the first time
Pyongyang provided evidence
to back its claim that it
has tactical nuclear warheads
but could be mounted on its missiles.
By the beginning of April,
Pyongyang said an underwater
drone it tested twice
is capable of conducting nuclear attacks.
Referring to an earlier
exercise, state media
said the drone could trigger a
quote, "Radioactive tsunami."
(dramatic music)
On April 13th, in another first,
(head popping)
Pyongyang launched a solid fueled
intercontinental ballistic missile.
(missile booming)
Experts said if this solid
fuel technology is perfected,
the long range weapon
can be deployed faster
and is harder to detect.
The missile traveled
for more than 600 miles
before landing in waters
east of the Korean peninsula.
The US and the UN condemned the test.
- The Secretary General
reiterates his call
on the Democratic
People's Republic of Korea
to fully comply with its
international obligations
under all relevant Security
Council resolutions
to reopen communications channels
and to resume dialogue leading
to sustainable peace and the complete
and verifiable denuclearization
of the Korean peninsula.
(tanks whooshing)
- [Narrator] North Korea
said the launch was part
of its response to consecutive
joint military drills
between the US and South Korea.
(soldiers shouting)
(pensive music)
Less than a week after the launch,
Pyongyang said it finished building
the country's first spy satellite,
which is aimed at collecting
real-time information
on the US military and its allies.
Shortly after state media released photos
of Kim and his daughter visiting
the country's space agency,
he ordered the launch
of the satellite without
giving an exact date.
- Welcome to the White House.
- [Narrator] On April 26th,
South Korean president,
Yoon Suk-yeol, met with
President Biden in the US.
Both leaders vowed to
take overwhelming action
if North Korea launches a nuclear attack.
The allies will set up a
group to share information
on nuclear operations and planning
and the US will send strategic assets
to South Korea regularly.
(missile booming)
Experts said the latest spree
of missile launches and
display of new technology
show North Korea's weapons
program has made rapid gains
and the advances are expected to continue.
(dramatic music)